if you had to today if we had 100 and
you bought gold and i bought bitcoin
with it in five years on the us dollar
conversion rate which one do you think
would be higher in five years well i
mean my guess would be gold but you know
i mean i bet you a million
dollars look you don't you don't have to
bet me you're already betting you have
all your money in bitcoin you know i i
have no money in bitcoin so no i bet you
a million dollars cold cash i'll pay you
in gold if you want
five years time i don't need to i don't
want to bet you where it's gonna be
maybe bitcoin will be higher so i don't
i don't you know i i i just don't see
saying this
i don't think it will but it might be
but meanwhile i don't i don't i don't i
don't see any reason because
i'm not making bets with everybody so
many people want to bet me on bitcoin
what else would you give it what odds
would you give it
that bitcoin will be higher than gold
yeah
in five years time
i i don't know i'm not an odds maker i
mean it's certainly possible that it
could be higher i mean i mean could the
bubble go on
i'll be a hundred thousand dollars i'll
give you ten to one
yes that's pretty good odds
i'll i'll think about it you think about
it yeah
you know but we have to find some way to
make sure that you pay me
i don't know that you'll actually have
any ability to pay me if i actually had
that bet and i knew you're going to pay
me then i can actually buy bitcoin
because i have like a free put on it
because
if it goes down
right
that allows me to create a situation
where i can't lose except your credit
worthiness is my is my risk why isn't it
a hundred thousand you know how many
people have come on i see on television
all the time they still have hundred
thousand dollar price targets for the
end of the year even today there's less
than a month
did you say gold was getting a 5 000 it
will
i never made a hat out of it though yeah
that's because you're not as
entrepreneurial
but you got people saying it's going to
be at 100 000 no are you guys still
thinking it's gonna be a hundred
thousand this year is that still your
forecast i i finally all right i think i
still here i still see people coming on
cnbc picking this year 100 000. i think
on a probability basis that there's uh
still a chance doesn't mean that it's
guaranteed to happen but i think that
there's still a very good just always a
chance you're gonna bet me on a hundred
thousand by the way you don't think it's
gonna go anything yeah you give me a
hundred to one odds on 100 grand by the
end of the year
look yeah you know
you may have a one percent chance no
would you give me a hundred to one odds
on 100 grand by the end of the year
no
because it probably there might be
watching one in a hundred shot that he
could would you give me uh five to one
odds
on a hundred grand by the end of the
year
um
i mean i so what do you mean